der nächste redner ist derweil gottfried
curio innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion sehr guter präsident meine
damen und herren viele hunderttausende
abgelehnte asylbewerber werden weiter
voll versorgt dafür wurde der absurde
status einer berechtigung der
unberechtigten erfunden die duldung
viele sind aber selbst nach diesem
pervertierten rechtsverständnis
abzuschieben vollziehbar was aber
geschieht die zahl der abschiebungen
sinkt immer weiter die zahl
ausreisepflicht ja steigt jeder zweite
abschiebung scheitert die leute tauchen
ab leisten widerstand greifen die
polizei an oder einer ruft plötzlich
nach dem arzt
er fühlt sich nicht gut und diese leute
kassieren weiter der bürger der das hört
fühlt sich noch viel weniger gut wie
wird hiermit recht und ordnung wie mit
dem von ihm erarbeiteten steuergeld
umgegangen meine damen und herren
die koalition hat nun an vielen kleinen
stellschrauben ein wenig gedreht über 50
seiten gesetzentwurf sind das so schwer
ist es unter dieser regierung geltendes
recht durchzusetzen
jüngst wurde der entwurf noch erweitert
die polizei dürfe sogar die wohnung des
abzuschieben betreten zum zwecke seiner
ergreifung was für eine klarstellung ja
wenn nötig dürfe man die wohnung sogar
durchsuchen was für harte jungs wird
auch im innenministerium haben in berlin
nämlich lässt die spd abschiebungen
einfach nicht mehr regelrecht
durchführen unterkünfte dürfen nicht
mehr betreten werden auch zwang soll
verzichtet werden
die polizei wird dem asylbetrüger wohl
eine einladung aussprechen sich doch an
abschiebung vollzug bitte zu beteiligen
kultur sensibel definitiv und
rassistisch vermutlich stärkt das sogar
den zusammenhalt zwischen diesen
herrschaften und ihrer beute dem
deutschen sozialstaat
es fehlt aber
am politischen willen tatsächlich die
hunderttausenden unberechtigten wieder
aus dem land zu bringen stattdessen
belässt das neue bildungsgesetz die
abgelehnten durch spurwechsel im land
man ist dann mal in ausbildung und
abschiebungen scheitern oft weil die
personen gewarnt werden reaktion im
gesetzentwurf weitgehende straffreiheit
für das durchstechen des termins das
gesetz lässt seine eigene vereitelung
straffrei vielmehr muss man darüber
schon nicht mehr sagen wenn abschiebung
so schwer ist sollte man vielleicht mal
die grenze schützen statt
hunderttausende weiter ungehindert
reinzulassen
auch der ruf frontex stärken bringt kein
grenzschutz dort registriert man nur und
winkt durch in wahrheit will die groko
die masse der illegalen in deutschland
behalten
so wird die spaltung der gesellschaft
weiter vorangetrieben am wohnungsmarkt
wo es dann für deutsche niedrigverdiener
zu wenig bezahlbaren wohnraum gibt am
arbeitsmarkt konkurrenzkampf lohndumping
bei der gelebten heimat wo mit viel
tausendfacher kultur fremder zuwanderung
geprägter lebensraum von lang her ererbt
unwiederbringlich verloren geht bei der
zugehörigen diffamierung von jedem der
das ganze inklusive heimatverlust und
finanzielle beratung nicht toll findet
wir sagen schluss damit
mit diesem gesetz mit diesem gesetz
solle noch einmal arbeitsfähigkeit
vorgetäuscht werden aber was für
verrenkungen was für regelungs akrobatik
statt einfach zu sagen grenze wird ab
jetzt gesichert sechzehner grundgesetz
gilt wieder syrien krieg ist aus bei
kriminalität ausweisung für
schutzbedürftige sachleistungen
integration in richtung heimatland doch
nichts von alledem eine grundsätzliche
wende hin zum effektiven ist nicht
erwünscht
stattdessen wird dieser kleine tausch
zwischen cora kumpels vorgenommen ein
bisschen recht im abschiebung gesetz
gegen unrecht im bildungsgesetz alle
wege dieses programmierten misslingens
führen ins dauer bleiberecht samt
familiennachzug samt überwiegend
staatliche alimentation ein
alljährliches sich zehn milliarden grad
nein meine damen und herren die
fortsetzung dieses koalitions versucht
ist nur noch ein trauerspiel deshalb
schluss damit dauer groko ist trauer
groko anderthalb jahre regierungs
bildungs versuch sind genug die
demokratische legitimation ist
verbraucht geben sie die entscheidung
wieder zurück zurück in die hand des
souveräns fortschritt curio für die
öffentliche fraktion